and we just made it all a bucket
and we said, "Men and women are different."
We got used to it and we never challenged it again,
and it's fascinating to me,
and by fascinating I mean a little bit insane,
that we still talk about this as a segment
when it's most likely carryover bias.
In fact, I don't come to this conclusion lightly.
We have enough data to suggest that gender is not the best place
to start for you to design and target your brands.
And I would even go one step further:
unless you are working in a very gender-specific product category,
probably anything else
you're hypothesizing about your consumer right now
is going to be more useful than gender.
We did not set up to draw this conclusion specifically.
We found it.
As consultants, our job is to go with our clients
and understand their business
and try to help them find spaces for their brands to grow.
And it is our belief that if you want to find disruptive growth in the market,
you have to go to the consumer
and take a very agnostic view of the consumer.
You have to go and look at them from scratch,
remove yourself from biases and segments that you thought were important,
just take a look to see where the growth is.
And we built ourselves an algorithm precisely for that.
So imagine that we have a person
and we know a person is making a choice
about a product or service,
and from this person, I can know their gender, of course,
other demographics, where they live, their income, other things.
I know the context where this person is making a decision,
where they are, who they're with,
the energy, anything,
and I can also put other things in the mix.
I can know their attitudes,
how they feel about the category,
their behaviors.
So if you imagine this kind of blob of big data about a person --
I'm going to oversimplify the science here
but we basically built an algorithm for statistical tournaments.
So a statistical tournament is like asking this big thing of data,
"So, data, from everything you know about consumers at this point,
what is the most useful thing I need to know
that tells me more about what consumers need?"
So the tournament is going to have winners and losers.
The winners are those variables, those dimensions,
that actually teach you a lot about your consumer,
that if you know that, you know what they need.
And there's losing variables that are just not that practical,
and this matters because in a world of limited resources,
you don't want to waste it on people that actually have the same needs.
So why treat them differently?
So at this point, I know, suspense is not killing you,
because I told you what the output is,
but what we found over time
is after 200 projects around the world -- this is covering 20 countries or more --
in essence we ran about a hundred thousand of these tournaments,
and, no surprise, gender was very rarely the most predictive thing
to understand consumer needs.
From a hundred thousand tournaments,
gender only came out as the winning variable
in about five percent of them.
This is true around the world, by the way.
We did this in places where traditional gender roles
are a little more pronounced,
and the conclusions were exactly the same.
It was a little bit more important, gender, than five percent,
but not material.
So let's let that sink in for a second.
No matter how you're looking at a consumer,
most likely anything else is going to be more interesting to you than gender.
There's probably something very important you need to know about them,
and you're getting distracted because you're doing everything based on gender.
And that's why I say you're leaving money on the table.
Gender is easy. It's easy to design advertising based on gender,
it's easy to target people online and on TV based on gender.
But at the end, that's not where the exciting growth will come from.
If you're a food company, for example, it's actually much more interesting to you
to know where people are eating, who they are eating with,
are they very nutritionally oriented.
All of those things are actually significantly more powerful and useful
than knowing if a person is a man or a woman.
And that matters, of course,
because then if you're putting your limited budget into action,
then you're better off creating solutions for different occasions
than trying to target women versus young men.
Another example is alcoholic beverages.
Thirty-five percent to 40 percent of consumption in alcoholic beverages
around the world actually happens with women,
but, you know, "women don't drink beer."
Those are the things that we typically hear.
But actually, when a man and a woman are, for the most part, in the same location,
the emotional and functional needs they have at that moment
are very similar.
There's only one exception, by the way,
and the exceptions exist,
where if you have a man and a woman
on a date,
the man is trying to impress the woman
and the woman is trying to connect with the man,
so there's going to be a little bit of tension,
but that's important to know.
We'll take a few dates.
Financial institutions: that's something where we've heard a lot
about the difference between men and women,
but actually talking about men and women as different
is distracting you from the thing that is underneath.
We made it so simple as "women don't like to invest,"
"women hate managing their money,"
"men are great and aggressive and risk-takers,"
but at the end it's not about men and women.
It is actually a different narrative.
It is about, there are people that are excited and energized
and educated to manage their finances
versus people that are not.
So if you change the conversation
from men and women to actually what's underneath
then probably you'll stop being so condescending to women
and you may start serving some men
that are actually shy about managing their finances.
I'll leave one more example.
If I go back to the women that were playing sport at the beginning,
one of the fascinating things we found over different countries,
exploring sportswear,
that if a person is a competitive person
and they are in the moment of action,
the needs are not different between a man and a woman.
An athlete is an athlete.
It doesn't matter for men and women, it doesn't matter for old and young,
you are an athlete,
and in the moment of action and extreme competition,
you need this gear to work for you.
So these soccer-playing women have a lot in common with their counterparts.
Out of the field, it doesn't matter.
Out of the field, they may be into fashion, into other things,
but on the field, the needs are not different.
So these are just a few examples on categories where we found
that gender was not the best place to go,
and actually the argument is
that at this point it's not even a feminist push,
it's just we got used to it.
We got used to using gender,
and it's important for us to start finding ways
to measure other things about consumers
so that we don't revert back to gender.
I am not naïve,
and I know there's still going to be appetite
and certain ease around using gender,
but at least this warrants a conversation.
In your business, you have to inquire,
is this really the best lens for me to grow.
So, if you are, like me, a person that is in business,
that I am constantly worried about what is my role
in the broader societal discussions,
if you're listening to your business and you hear things like,
"Oh, my target are women, my target are men,
this goes to young girls, young boys,"
when it's that gender conversation,
unless you are working, again,
in a very specific, gender-specific product category,
take this as a warning sign,
because if you keep having these conversations,
you will keep perpetuating stereotypes of people
and making people think that men and women are different.
But because this is business, and we're running a business,
and we want to grow it,
at least kind of challenge your own instinct to use gender,
because statistics say that you're probably not choosing the best variable
to target your product or service.
Growth is not easy at all.
What makes you think that growth is going to come
from going into market with such an outdated lens like gender?
So let's stop doing what's easy and go for what's right.
At this point, it's not just for your business, it's for society.
Thank you.
(Applause)